expand the vegas loop soon the company
will present a franchise agreement to
the county to get the ball rolling we
have joe mohler live outside the
convention center with what is happening
next joe
brian we are now getting a look at that
61-page agreement that the county
commissioners are set to vote on
happening here at the convention center
as a business aviation convention a lot
of attendees have been going through
that loop and soon even more visitors
and locals will be able to
the boring company will be submitting a
17.5 million dollar franchise agreement
to county commissioners tuesday the
newest map revised just days ago shows
routes just east of the strip and an
additional stop at allegiant stadium
convention goers say expanding it would
bring them back i think it's a fantastic
idea to be honest with you i mean it's
super convenient and it really brings
something just to let you know like
actually like i took
like a video of it the boring company's
loop at the convention center first
opened in june and will soon connect to
resorts world the agreement did not
detail a timeline of the project
now back out here live county
commissioners will take a look at this
agreement on tuesday at 9 a.m and they
will also hold a public hearing
reporting live at the convention center
this evening joe muller live local now